♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Okay it's tea with Gary Vee. ♪
♪ Sipping instant tea ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Put it up all my shit for free ♪
♪ This is tea with Gary Vee ♪
♪ Mike don't make a flick ♪
♪ Take a ♪
- This is Tea With GaryVee.
And I am Gary Vee.
Hope everybody super well.
I'm fired up.
It is April 17th.
Feeling energized by the All in Challenge.
Where are we at right now.
All in Challenge.
I expect everybody who
gets $7.4 million dollars
raised in the first three
days at the All in Challenge.
I'm super flattered, super excited,
super humbled by all the support
from everybody in this community.
And Dustin, do we have a
tiny URL or GaryVee URL
or my All in challenge?
6I want to...
Get the team to do that
garyvee.com/allinchallenge,
- Okay.
- and then we can put that down here
because I want everybody
who's watching, Dustin.
Dustin, you said yesterday
that you bought raffle tickets
to have the Ultimate GaryVee Experience
- I did.
- Oh crap, Dustin, I'm a
little bit worried right now
'cause I know it's been so
crazy for our whole team
'cause we've all been on this.
Did you make it so that
when this episode ends,
it ends with the (mumbles).
- I did.
(laughs)
- My man.
I'm proud of you.
- Thanks.
(laughs)
I'm proud of you.
All right, get out of here.
Give me my first guest.
Good morning, good morning, good morning.
For Nazdar, what's good?
What's good Dr. Neal 1973.
Rachel K.
Kara Link.
Good to see you.
Greg Remillard.
What's good, what's good?
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Good, how are you?
- I'm well, Megan, what's going on?
How are feeling now?
- My question for you is, how
do I make a consistent monthly
income as a motivational speaker,
author, Blogger, YouTuber?
Because right now I make,
I would say 95% sending my
money one on one sessions,
I speak to teenagers.
So, I'm just trying to think
of how I can make money
doing speaking gigs.
- I think what you can do,
if you're speaking one
on one to teenagers,
if that's your framework,
I think you should start a monthly club
for parents of teenagers
where the club gets a
video each week from you
on things you've learned
from talking to teenagers,
and each of them get invited to a close
or two hour live session
with you every month.
So, it's group sessions, group sessions,
so you can scale
and original content
exclusive for that group.
It's 19, 29, 49, $89 a month,
I think and then you start
marking towards that.
And now all of a sudden
you have 1000 people
paying you $89 a month,
you'd be $9,000 a month
in recurring revenue,
you're making a million
dollars in revenue on the back
of 24 hours a month of group sessions,
and four videos a month.
And I think for a lot
of parents with anxiety
of like what to do with their teenagers,
if I made that business tomorrow,
I'd probably make $10 million a year.
- Yeah.
I love it.
Oh my god.
No, thank you so much (laughs).
- You're welcome so much.
Have a great day.
- Thank you.
- Dustin, that's how you do it.
Get on here.
I just want to talk about that first call.
Because that's real shit right there.
- Honestly, wasn't paying
attention (laughs).
- Okay (mumbles).
Agent Jezel, what's good?
What's good Kevin Anthony?
Morning, Brad.
Eric, you know what's funny?
When he says, "Give it away for free."
Eric, what's interesting is
she was asking how to make revenue.
How do you build the biggest brand?
How do you make the most
revenue that is around free?
And what would happen next
Eric, by the way, who just brought up,
I thought you're gonna
say give it away for free,
is that she will put out
a ton of content for free.
But then for people that want
something even more detailed,
where you know, and then even more access,
it's there, right?
And so, you can give away a lot of free
but giving away for free forever
and not building a business model
is a vulnerability for some.
I don't like when people
package up and make a $997 ebook
with just regurgitated
stuff you can find for free,
but when you layer a one
hour meaningful video
where you really go through shit,
and it's unique every week,
and you give them two hours
of your time, once a month,
now you're starting to add
to value and micro payments,
90 bucks or less a month.
You know, you can, for
somebody who's a parent
with anxiety with a
teenager at, let's call it,
let's say she decided to go 30
bucks a month for $360 a year
for 52 weeks worth of one hour videos,
and for 24 hours worth of
access time where maybe
three times you get your question asked
like this, becomes valuable.
And it's about being proud
and feeling valuable about what you sell.
You're welcome (mumbles).
I love this, this is fun.
This is, the show's exploding.
Let's keep it going.
King Seez, what's good?
Brandon.
- Yeah, what's up man?
- Brandon, what's up man?
It's good to see you.
- How are you?
Great to see you.
- Good man, they got you
- How are things?
- in here, it makes me happy.
I'm doing well, it's good to see you.
- So, like you, I speak for
a living and it's my life.
So, with everything that's been going on,
my business has been
absolutely annihilated.
Nobody's booking and everything that I had
has either been canceled
or pushed back for months.
So, my mission--
- And by the way, Brandon, right away,
you better assume all of
those that are pushed back
are going to be canceled.
- I know.
- Last night I was telling my parents,
and I make a lot of money speaking,
I was like, this year is shot to zero.
And next year, I think is gonna
be 20% of what it would be.
- Well.
- I'm sorry to say that,
but I want you to have the best advice.
I could be wrong but I think
until there's a vaccine,
think about it, if it's
January, there's no vaccine,
and you're the kind of company
that puts on a conference
and you would put it on in March,
you're not gonna do that.
And so you're gonna wait,
and let's say it comes in April or May,
then they're gonna be like,
okay, fuck it, do we do
in November or December?
It's gonna...
So, Bran listen, you really
have to strategize right now,
and that's why we're here.
You're gonna have to make
the assumption that this year
and next year are gone.
And by the way, you and
I are massively affected,
but so is Lady Gaga, and
Bruno Mars, and Drake,
people don't understand
how much money is made
and actual stuff of that nature,
so, it's (mumbles) Live Nation.
This is a very challenging time
for people that draw people together.
- Yeah, so I have a mission
to elevate out at the end,
I want to push people
to become the greatest
version of themselves.
So, with that being said,
I would love to know,
in your opinion what other
possibilities you think
that I should explore and
kind of where to go from here.
- If I didn't run VaynerMedia,
I would be living on
the internet right now.
I'd be live.
I'd be doing Tea with GaryVee,
Lunch with GaryVee,
Cocktails with GaryVee,
Dinner with GaryVee, Late
Night Drinks with GaryVee.
And I'm not kidding.
I would probably, if I
did not run, if I was you.
If I was just GaryVee,
not Gary Vaynerchuk,
which is what I'm 90% of.
But if I was just Gary Vee,
I would be on the internet 12 to 20 hours.
Not 20.
I'd be on 12 to 15 hours
a day doing Q&A like this.
- Wow, okay.
- If you're if your mission is
to elevate empathy in the world,
you can do it more this way
than you can do speaking.
- It's so true.
- I'm aware.
- And I see the opportunities
that are coming out of this
are so great and so much more substantial
then you're exactly right.
Those speaking gigs in those stages.
- Now the speaking gigs
are more financially fruitful right now.
- Yeah.
- My hope and dream is that
you've saved some money
can kind of weather the storm.
If you didn't, and you
overextended yourself,
you're gonna now need to convert dollars
from the internet which
is gonna let you...
Put you in a tricky spot,
because the second you charge for it,
you can't build as much scale.
I'm so grateful, knock on
wood, that I'm doing tea...
I mean, right now, a stunning
percentage of my audience
is saying Tea with GaryVee
is the single best thing
I've ever done for them quality wise.
- Yeah.
- And I'm grateful that
I can do it for free.
And by the way, if I was just GaryVee,
and didn't have all the
diversity of everything I do,
I probably would have not been able
to do all of it for free.
Maybe I would do 10 hours for free.
And then probably or I
would take donations.
- Okay.
- Well, listen--
- Like Patreon
- Yeah, or build my own little execution.
The truth is because I
haven't looked at donations
I'm not even sure the
donation infrastructure,
but if you look at China,
we're gonna see that happen here in the US
with Tick Tock and things of that nature,
you're gonna see every phase...
Instagram Live is gonna have
a donations button for you
while you're on live.
I believe that to be true.
So, definitely for nonprofits, but I mean,
for you, tips, tips, tip jar,
just like somebody playing the piano
or someone in the street,
like, that's real talk.
I think I would...
If I did Tea with GaryVee
for 12 hours a day
and it was free, but there was a tip jar,
I have a funny fucking feeling.
I said this the other day
of how much would you pay for this?
And a bunch of people
answered in the comments.
I'm gonna ask this question.
Hey, everybody who's watching right now,
if I was doing this
right now 12 hours a day,
how often would you tip if...?
Would you tip at all?
And the answer is zero for some people
(mumbles) do not fucking tipping.
And how much would you tip?
Leave a comment.
I think it would be interesting.
So, I think Bran, that's
where you need to think about.
- Okay.
- Build brand...
Listen, Brandon, when
there's times like this,
it's time to build a brand.
What everybody's doing
is trying to make sales.
- Right.
- Got it?
- Absolutely man.
So much love for you.
Thank you.
- Take care yourself.
Yep, there you go.
Facebook, this is how little
I look at the tip infrastructure.
Facebook right now has its tip jar.
That's right.
I actually did know that.
So yeah, maybe we should put it up.
(laughs)
We should, maybe I will
put it up, fuck it.
Take the money and do some garage sale
and buy some sports cards.
All right, let's keep it going.
Actually, I might do
that just for the data.
- Gary.
- Dustin, Joe one second.
Dustin, take a look at what's going on
with the Facebook tip infrastructure.
Let's get like my bank
account like all set up
like let's talk to Andy and Jim.
I just wanna, guys if I
do this tomorrow or soon.
I'm gonna donate...
I don't, I gotta figure...
I'd wanna to do it for the data.
I might donate.
Okay, we'll figure it out.
I think that's awesome.
All right, let's get back.
Joe, what's good?
- Gary What's up, man?
- I'm well.
- Oh, awesome.
Thank you so much for having me on.
So, just to kind of get into it,
I am a pasta manufacturer in
- Love it.
- right outside
of Philadelphia.
- Love it.
- I've been doing this for 10 years.
- Yes, sir.
- So, as I said in my, when I
was talking with with Dustin
is we've had a lot of,
I started from nothing,
so nothing to, you know,
we're doing pretty well here.
I've taken my lumps in retail stores,
and distributor stuff like that.
So, we're at a place right now
where we have really
good customer engagement.
We're getting some nice
inquiries over the internet,
but I know for a fact my
product is really good,
but I also--
- You've delicious
fucking pasta.
(mumbles)
- Okay.
I also know that my marketing is just
not where the quality product is.
- So, you've delicious fucking
pasta and dog shit marketing.
- Hundred percent.
- Okay.
- And I'm, and honestly I've
been doing this for 10 years
and the last couple years I've
been really looking at myself
and like, not giving
myself bullshit of like,
I'm doing a good job, you're
doing this now I'm like
at the point where I'm
like, you know what, no,
I'm not doing a good job.
- Good.
- So...
- Good for you.
Yeah, so So my question is, you know,
I think I sell to too many people.
We have a wholesale
business that we sell to.
So that's B2B.
And then we have our B2C that
we have a direct consumer.
And I feel like I'm caught
in between both of them
and I'm not giving--
- Either enough?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, first and foremost,
you want hundred percent
what your DTC business to
get your ABCDE (mumbles),
even though your B2B business
is where your business is.
- Right, 'cause that
like my bread and butter,
that's my weekly, my restaurants...
Well, not right now my
restaurants (mumbles).
but that's your vulnerability.
Your vulnerability is that
you're making your money
in the thing that isn't your future
and that's where you're getting caught.
- Okay.
Okay.
- So from a focus standpoint,
not necessarily dollars
but especially right now more
than ever, right this second.
If I'm you based on
everything I just heard,
I'm 100...
I'm spending 18 to 20 hours a day
because you're young you
can you can pull a couple
for hours, I did last
night I clocked out 11
because it was dead.
So I got a nice little
seven, eight, actually,
I needed it because the fours fucked me up
I need five, I need six
really to do my thing,
I can get away with
five without being dead
but fours fuck me.
But you need to be fucking
going crazy on Pinterest,
crazy on running a $10
Atom and sort of Swipe-Ups
to see if it works.
You need to you need to
build your B2C business,
not restaurants, not retailers,
'cause the way to build a healthy business
is to have your business be amortized
over 15,000 people that
buy your pasta, not 12.
- Right.
Yeah, because I mean, as of right now
we're going crazy with the virus.
I mean, we're really busy right now,
which is, I'm so down.
- Why?
- Dry pasta, because
no one can get it and--
- And so are you selling to?
Consumers?
- Well, it's all of our
online markets that sell.
We're on Amazon and we're
going, work in order (mumbles).
- Amazon?
- Yeah, 400% more than what we
usually get, which is great.
I'm so thankful for that.
- But Amazon then becomes
the middleman too.
I want you to build
your own infrastructure
to sell direct to consumer.
- Okay, so and that's, so that's perfect.
So (mumbles) you're saying that
because I guess that was...
That's the justification I needed.
It's 'cause we want to do fresh pasta
delivered to your door.
- We're about to launch
something at Vayner,
You should email me.
I don't know if you're
gonna be able to afford it,
but we're about to, we're trying to create
a low product blueprint in
our commerce capabilities,
because I'm getting
emailed 40,000 times a day.
I'm trying to figure out,
so because I love small
business, I'm like,
okay, if I take my assets, and
I move them to this product,
and it's a $15 $15,000 blueprint,
and I sell a bunch of those,
because I can get the $4
million from one client.
I'm trying to figure it out.
I'd like to do both right now.
It's chaotic, and I have so
many people that actually know
what they're doing.
But that's what you need.
You need to figure out that world.
- Okay, yeah, it's like I'm--
- Real quick, everybody
wants to buy your pasta.
So, what's the name of the pasta?
And is that on Amazon?
- It is on Amazon.
- Hold on, watch this.
You're about to sell so
much fucking pasta bro.
Hold on one second.
- It's called verapasta.com.
- Oh, so but if the term Amazon,
'cause that's gonna be easy for everybody.
What is it?
V...
- V-E-R-A...
- Yep.
- P-A-S-T-A.
- Did you just fucking
spell pasta for me, bro.?
- I did brother.
(laughs)
- I appreciate it.
- I'm so used to doing it
'cause people can never
understand (laughs).
- So, is it called pasta?
Is it Pasta Vera?
- Vera Pasta.
It's...
- So, it's different.
- Yeah
- Pasta Vera
is something different?
- Yeah, it should have like
a craft bag on there.
- So, wait a minute,
there's a ton of Pasta Vera,
are those fuckers...?
Are you pissed to those guys
'cause people get confused sometimes?
- Yeah, I tried to, TM and
and they wouldn't let me
'cause pasta is too general, so.
- Oh, wait I see it now, Vera Pasta,
it's got like the big red, Vera Pasta Co?
- Yeah, that's it.
- All right my man, let me see here.
- Appreciate.
- Vera Pasta, (mumbles) and
then a three pack is 24.99?
- Correct.
- Damn, shit is about
to go ham for you bro.
- (laughs) I appreciate.
One last question, I won't
take that much of your time.
I love what you do as
far as you are the brand
and you're giving back,
you're giving people a content
and stuff like that and I
want to be like an authority
in the Italian food pasta.
- So make content.
- There you go, okay.
Would you do...?
- Bro it's...
- Yeah, 'cause--
- Yeah, whenever you're
about to say would you do?
The answer is yes.
(laughs)
The difference between me
and a lot of people is,
anytime I say what I do, I do
it because of two core things.
One humility, one, two self confidence.
The humility to not value
my time at my level.
- Correct.
- At my level.
Go and do it for a month and have it fail.
That's humility.
I don't overvalue my time.
Everybody hears like valuing their time
when their timing work shit.
And two, the confidence
that it fucking sucks
that my dad my brother,
my best friend, the world
is like you fucking failed.
I'm like, yeah.
- Yeah.
- You're supposed to micro fail.
- Yeah, I've heard a lot of that (laughs).
- No, you're supposed to micro fail.
- I know.
- The only thing you
can make fun of me for
is if I go out of business.
If I don't, fuck you.
I'm supposed to be micro failing.
I'm making fun of you for
fucking thinking about shit.
I'm doing out here.
I'm fucking doing out here.
- Hundred percent.
- Would I?
Yes, motherfucker.
Yes, Vera Pasta, P-A-S-T-A.
I would fucking do it.
(laughs)
Make shit.
Let's go.
- Awesome.
- By the way your website crashed.
(laughs)
- Fix that shit.
See you later.
- All right brother.
- Let's keep it going.
I wasn't joking your website crashed.
- Oh, Jesus (laughs).
- Yeah, talk to you later.
- Thanks.
Dustin.
- Yes, sir.
- We need that whole video
chat for Instagram,
especially the way it ended.
That was fucking amazing.
(laughs)
Thank you.
- Yep.
- Speaking of a website that won't crash,
you know where I'm going
Dustin, give it to me.
Okay, listen to me, yesterday
a good chunk of you signed up,
but I'm fucking pissed.
People, keyboard warriors,
talking about how much
they're gonna donate to
me and they buy Wine.
Do not, by the way, cost
money to send a text,
it's not email.
So, do not sign up for
WineText if you don't buy Wine.
Do not sign up for
WineText if you buy Wine.
Not, if you don't buy Wine
at least once a month.
But I'm telling you with all my heart,
and I need to see the
comments for verification
that you just did it.
And I need you to go to Twitter.
And you should literally
do it while we're watching
this right now and go to Twitter.
Sign up, screen shoot the
confirmation that you signed up
for WineText and then go to Twitter,
GaryVee here's my screen.
If you buy Wine once a month
at the store, at wine.com
at Total Wine, at the Super
Market, Publix, Albertsons,
at Costco at fucking Trader Joe's,
if you buy Wine, once a month,
if you buy one once a month
and you fucking are not
signed up for WineText,
you're fucking breaking my dad's heart.
America only, there's
about seven to 10 states
we can't ship to, I'm sorry, Illinois.
I'm sorry, Michigan,
I'm sorry, Texas, Utah,
but I'm telling you, if you're
21 and older, see the 15.
Or if you'd like me in any way,
can you take the URL of WineText
and post on your LinkedIn,
your Twitter, your Facebook
and say you should sign up for this.
It's an incredible service 'cause it is.
'Cause it's fucking crazy.
Today's the...
Let me see if Brandon emailed me.
Give me a preview for today's deal.
Fucking phone has been like (mumbles).
'Cause it is, I want to see
who's signing up, no Canada.
Canada people you've got
to buy Empathy Wines.
Empathy Wines Canada, just type that in,
empathy wines Canada.
Today's is either gonna be
$45, fuck, a $45 Chardonnay
for 19.37 a bottle, 93 points
or a 94 point Pinot Noir.
That's 60 bucks for 28.88.
Actually in the comments say if..
Actually you're gonna control
it in a team with Gary Vee,
type in pasta...
Jesus fucking Christ, type
in Chardonnay or Pinot Noir,
in the comments, tell
me which one I should do
and definitely sign up
for WineText fucking...
You can sign your mom up.
I mean, you should get her approval.
You need her credit card
when you sign up, so.
(mumbling)
Okay, let's keep going.
And who signed up for, Paige.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
Good, okay, well I actually
just all the sudden got
super nervous.
So (laughs).
- Don't be.
- Okay, so I had an original question.
And I kind of have this thing
of like dealing with things
myself and so I watched
a bunch of your videos,
pretty much answered my own first question
and I came up with a new one.
- Awesome with that.
- So, if you you see--
- I apologize Paige, I
decided to do something.
Colton Lewin, I'm retweeting your sign-up,
I'm retweeting...
I'm retweeting Luis, I'm
retweeting yours as well,
I'm gonna retweet these screenshots,
'cause I want people to be
able to get some love too.
All right, Paige, go ahead,
I'm into what you're doing.
- Okay, so, if you kind of
like manifest your own thoughts
and you put out what you
want to receive kind of deal,
how do you balance between
your losses and your wins
posting them on social media
or putting that out there?
Because some people think
the whole two steps forward,
one step back and you wanna
see the whole process,
but how do you balance that out?
Because you don't wanna constantly post
all the negative things that happen?
- Well, I think micro negative is great.
- Right, I know, I just wrote
that down your micro loss,
your micro failing.
- Right?
So what are you scared of?
That you're like Debbie Downer,
if you're constantly posting (mumbles).
- Yeah, I don't,
yeah so--
- Or do you wanna...
Or do you want these people to
be convinced that you're good
'cause you need them to
convert into something?
'cause that would make sense to me.
That's not a bad thing.
I'm just trying to
understand the question.
- So, not really a conversion,
I'm really big into like
health and wellness, so--
- Actually I apologize real
quick 'cause I wanna share this.
I bought a JV with like four
different publishing sites
and music and sports and
lost millions of dollars
when I was building VaynerMedia,
which taught me to buy PureWow.
And that's why One37
PureWow are doing well,
'cause I lost money buying last Letterman
and other things like that.
And I mean, there was a deal
I made for great music set,
I don't remember the fucking
names, six years ago,
I bought like 50% of it.
And then we didn't do as
much as I thought we would.
And we gave, and then
I gave all the equity
back to the person, just
had to write off 600,000.
- Okay.
So, it's just your own
balance, your own life,
I guess is what it comes down to and--
- Paige, i think people
are starting to push back
against people on Instagram
who just show glam.
- Yeah, I know for sure.
It's highly annoying.
- And how do you balance it?
You just fucking balance it
like some months there'll be 38%
negative and 62% positive and other times
it'll be the reverse.
- Okay.
- Talk, talk.
- Okay, well I'm really
nervous, all right, like this--
- Don't be, don't be, you're so amazing.
- (laughs) So, one of the big
things that I had an issue
with was posting.
I'm really good with typing things out
and I'm very passionate about people
and I want to help people
and I just felt like
every time I wrote something
with a little picture,
I was getting a lot of negative feedback
like why are you doing this?
That you're an idiot, this is not cool.
Like you're asking for
donations for people to,
who are already working.
I did a health care packages
for health care workers
and I was doing a fundraiser for that.
People were getting
really mad at me and it...
- What do they want you to do?
- I don't know and I didn't
want to, I don't know,
'cause I didn't really ask them.
They were just kind of
yelling at me about how
collecting money for
people who are working
is a terrible decision right now.
And I need to be thinking
about myself and other people
and people who don't have jobs.
And, I--
- So wait a minute, are you're
telling me that you were
taking donations to help
frontline caretakers
during this pandemic?
- Yes.
- And you were keeping none of the money?
- Okay.
Paige, listen to me, when
people are hurting they project.
Right now, 22 million
Americans have lost their job
in four weeks, from 2010 to 2020
during an economic explosion,
we created 22 million jobs.
So, in the last 10 years
up to this pandemic,
we had one of the great economic
runs in American history.
And all the jobs that were
created during that time,
have vanished in four weeks.
So, what's happening Paige is,
this has nothing to do with you,
you're over analyzing you.
What's happening is the
people that are saying that
are either one of the
people that lost their jobs,
or is the loved one of
somebody lost their jobs.
So right now, because it's
so easy to hide behind
the keyboard, people
projecting their anger.
So it requires, everything
I've been talking about
for the last few years about
self-esteem and strength
is gonna play out even
more now because the people
on the front lines of creating content,
whether for themselves to make money,
'cause they also have to live or anything
is going to require self-esteem.
Now, that doesn't mean that
people aren't toned up.
We have very wealthy
people putting out content
that is upsetting people.
And 'cause that's tone deaf,
but when you just explained
to me is a wildly nice act
of you taking your time
and efforts to try to help
the people that are helping us the most.
And what I'm worried about
is that you're over valuing
the comments when you're 100% right.
- Okay.
Wow, that was a whole
weight lifted off of me.
- But I don't want you to take
my validation for it either.
The weight came off because
you value my validation
and so now that countered
the anonymous validation,
so you feel better.
I want you to not value my validation.
I want you to not value their validation.
I want you to live with inside yourself.
- Okay.
- The reason I'm gonna win this
whole thing is nobody lives
in a more quiet place on earth than me.
There could be people
that are tied with me,
but my shit is quiet as fuck.
- Nice.
- Here's the key to get there.
- Thanks.
- You can't..
You're welcome.
You can't feel great when
you get positive validation.
- Okay.
- The reason I think, the
reason now I'm confident
that I can win this thing,
meaning be happy and make impact
and have a good life, is 'cause
now that I'm on a hot moment
where my brand has exploded,
I've got validation coming
from the highest levels in the
world, fame, politics money,
just I made it, right?
I don't believe that either.
I don't think I'm special.
- Okay.
- So, when somebody says
you're pretty or you're smart,
or that's a great idea,
you can't get high.
- Yeah.
- You got to stay quiet in the middle.
Because when somebody comes and
says you're a piece of shit,
you've already practiced for that moment.
When you overvalue complements,
people that tear you down, have leverage.
- Nice.
That's pretty heavy, Gary (laughs).
- I think so too, you
know, but it's the game.
What's great about this format is
I'm not rushed in the office.
I've got more time, I can articulate my,
I'm going a step deeper in my thoughts,
saying the same thing I've said before,
but in a different way.
That two minutes might be the
most impactful thing I've said
for a far majority my
audience, it's a big deal.
- Yeah.
- My happiness is
predicated on my humility.
- Okay.
That's super cool.
- It's awesome, happy to help you.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- Talk to you.
- Bye.
- Let's keep going.
Misha, what's good?
- (laughs) Gary, how you doing man?
- I'm really well.
- This is wild.
- Happy to have you.
- This is part of my whole
thing of being the luckiest
person in the world.
Literally, I've been in
the deep end of GaryVee.
I've known about you for years,
but like the deep end of
the pool for three months.
- I love it.
- I told my friends--
- What happened?
How did you know what the
piece of content was that
took the shallow end to the deep end?
I love podcasts and I go
for like a morning run
every morning and you
just kind of hype me up.
I'm kind of like, I like your energy.
So, it kind of gets me going, so.
- But how did you get into the first...?
I'm trying, I like learning.
What made you like one day you were like,
oh, yeah, I kind of know this
dude, I'm a little (mumbles)
and I'll just listen to one podcast hit,
and then just (mumbles) on.
- No. It's like...
Yes.
I mean, I listened to a
lot of different podcasts
and I like the fact that
you put out every day.
So there's new new content,
because like I listen
to Planet Money, but
it's like once a week,
it's like all right now
there's 800 podcasts already.
(mumbles) all of them.
So, with you, it's kind of like
every day there's something
new and even for the
15 minutes that I run,
I don't run that much like that far.
(laughing)
But you know what I'm saying?
- I know what you're
saying, go ahead, brother.
So, you're telling you're friends?
- Yeah, I'm telling them like,
hey, I'm about to talk to Gary Vee.
They're like, how'd you land that?
I'm like, I texted him.
(laughs)
There's the number like,
yeah, I did it like 10 times,
but it is what it is, so I just kind of,
but it's part of my luck.
So like to kind of set up
my two part question is
I was lucky to grow up in
Ukraine until I was 12.
Like, poor, because that,
you know, I grew up outside
of the bubble of US and people
don't get a lot of that.
It's sad, but two when I came here,
- Let me help everybody as
a former Soviet boy too.
When he's saying it's sad,
everybody is watching right now,
we're in the middle of a pandemic.
There's we just lost 22 million jobs.
And the structure of America is still
such a uncomfortable level of opportunity
compared to where me
and this man come from.
And most people come from
it is grossly underrated.
And so are the other great
democracies in the world
no matter what iteration
they're in right now.
Keep going.
- So, I agree with you but
when we came here I was 12.
And like 13, 14 got
right into construction
because we have to help
pay the bills and--
- Of course.
- So, I grew up really quick just working
with 50, 60 year old Ukrainians
and just kind of going at it.
- I love it.
- So that was--
- And those dogs are dirty.
Those dogs are dirty.
- Yeah.
You know, we're doing roofing,
you're like, hold my hand.
So it's kind of a lot of that stuff.
So I got to learn a lot
in the trade and all that.
Then, to, I like business,
and I think my parents
are amazing, my family's amazing
and they kind of instilled
in me like, I can do it.
You know, a lot of that.
So, in my whole--
- Of course, anybody who's got
optimism, and you can do it,
thinks they're lucky.
I knew that from the second
you opened your first mouth.
The first time you opened your mouth,
I'm like, oh, this guy's optimistic.
- I see negatives, even
in this situation today,
I'm, like, there's gonna be
positive outta all of this.
- There should be uncomfortable
levels of positive.
There's enormous amounts of people
that are gonna lose wealth,
take health off the equation,
anybody who loses somebody they care about
during this pandemic, it's devastating.
- Yeah.
- Karma, in the framework
of that we're talking
about business,
there's gonna be plenty
of people that lose money,
there's about to be people
that are gonna make an
enormous amount of money,
there's so much opportunity.
- I mean, also, think
about people that we will,
say, down the road 20 years from now,
because now we're not naive that,
we're gonna do germ games
and things like that,
we're gonna start thinking about
what could kill an economy
versus a war or whatever,
but,
- Yep.
- So, okay, besides that, my whole life,
I've kinda been chasing,
I believe that I have
greatness inside of me,
I don't know if that's naive
or is that like corky--
- I definitely know what
you're talking about.
- But, you know, I'm, like,
everything is so simple these days,
it's like, I could go for a
car ride with a friend of mine,
and I'm like, yo, we have
this idea, it's like,
dude, we should start a business,
I'm like, let's do it this weekend.
Let's get the website going, we can get,
its always, it's so simple these days,
and so, almost, for me as a person,
it's hard that it's so simple,
'cause, I can kinda lose my focus a lot.
- So, but, don't judge
yourself, so, all you have to do
is not make a big
statement when you start.
Don't tell everybody, like,
the way you protect yourself
from being unfocused and
stopping and starting,
is don't make a big statement
that you're gonna change
the world with this app.
Stay quiet for the first year,
instead of what most people
that are optimistic like you
and me do, which is the
second I do something,
like, this is gonna fucking,
and then three weeks in,
they change your fucking
mind, and then you're like,
oh fuck, I just thought,
and then you'll be the
boy that cries wolf.
So, stop fucking crying.
- Yeah, so,
- You see where I'm going though?
- I do, I get it, I do.
I should shut my mouth a little more
and just get through it.
- I know, bro,
I know who you are, because I'm listening,
that's why I just gave you that advice.
Good news, you have an
idea, start on Saturday,
you change your mind on Thursday
because I go fuck this, you're set.
Because you didn't tell
your mum, your dad,
your best friends
that you're gonna fucking
be Mark Zuckerberg.
- Yeah.
- Shut your fucking mouth.
- So, kind of to set up my question is,
I was lucky that I felt like
I got married super early
and I had kids super early,
but then at the same
time, I had my first son,
he's three now.
I started a business and went all in deep
into the business 'cause
I was, like, hey man,
Imma get this going within
the next three, four years,
I'll be freaking retired
and I'll just focus on my
kids, you know what I'm saying?
But that's gonna--
- Okay.
No, listen, that's amazing.
- I'm like, I'll get this going,
I'll get this done in like--
- No, what's so amazing
about that is, it's so naive,
do you know what, like, do
you know how Ludacris...
I wish I was your homie in your crew.
I feel like every crew
needs somebody like me,
I would, like, look at
you and be like, bro,
what are you fucking talking about?
(mumbles)
- Everybody was saying,
you need to just hustle, and
just hustle, hustle, hustle,
and then, you can you
now, manage the business.
But that's not like, so.
- That's stupid.
- I know, so, I mean, that was
one of things I've learned.
I get destroyed essentially,
my first time around I get destroyed.
- That's good.
- And
basically, what I got
out of that experience,
- Why?
Well,
'cause I rushed and chased the
home run versus the singles,
so, I used to live in New York, right now
I live in New Hampshire, but
I used to live in New York
and I got into this, with this dude,
renovating apartments.
So, it was like this massive thing like,
hey, I'll give you 50
apartments to renovate.
I'm hiring people, hiring
people we were like a 12 dudes,
I'm burning through 15,000 a week.
But a dry account though, you know?
Paycheck comes in, you just
pay the people because for me,
it's like, hey, I'm gonna
make it out of this.
But then the guy, I didn't
have a good infrastructure
for like paperwork (laughs).
You know, a lot of that.
So, the guy was just like,
hey, man, as soon as he passed
the inspection with
the builder, he's like,
hey, man, I don't like your
work, you're off the site.
And so that was kind of
literally just bankrupted me
right there.
And there's nothing I
could have done about that.
But it's fine because that's
a huge learning experience
from that.
(mumbles)
I walked away with that a better man,
but what my issue is, I
started the business again,
within, I lick my wounds,
I kind of cried about it
for a week, whatever.
Like, it's okay to do that.
- Of course it is okay.
- But within three months,
I had a new business
and kind of I went being the
best versus being the biggest
so like, right now we're
doing bathroom Renos
and I just want to be the best
bathroom renovation company
- I love that.
- Online or whatever.
- But the negative that I got out of it,
once I start reflecting on it is,
I missed almost a year of my kid's life.
'Cause looking at the pictures
and stuff on my phone,
it's all work work work.
So like,
- Bro.
- 'cause I've been like at 80,
20 family, 80 business.
- Bro.
I don't know if you heard.
There's no time machines.
I know.
- But so like, my thing is right now,
I love what you say is like,
I do believe personally,
I'm gonna live to like 120.
I'm healthy, I'm lucky again.
I'm lucky, so I do feel like
I'll miss the bus, you know?
- Yeah.
- But I think for the
next like 12 to 15 years
me and my wife who's
a rock stars, my wife,
she's my person and like literally,
she's the one I'll die next to, you know?
- Yeah.
- Whatever.
- It's super nice.
I love those couples where the
person, the one person dies
at 92,
- Yeah.
- And the next person dies
two weeks, four weeks later,
that's the final (mumbles)
- I know, it's...
So, we have this thing like,
let's focus on the family right now.
For the next like 12 to 15 years
because I know...
- It's perfect.
- Because I know that--
- All right, I got you.
Do it.
- I won't be able
to get that stuff back.
- Good.
No, no that's super smart.
- I have that itch though.
I still have that itch of--
- So, all that Misha make sense.
So audit everything else.
- What do you mean?
- What else do you do
besides spend time with
your family and work?
- (laughs)
I don't know friends--
- And I'm being, no, no.
I'm being real, real.
Meaning, do you watch TV?
- I do like after eight
o'clock, nine o'clock
with my wife for an hour.
- Then after, and then what
are you doing at 10 o'clock?
- I crash (laughs).
- Yeah, so,
what time do you wake up?
It's okay, let's play
let's play, this is not me.
I'm trying to come from a love place,
let's break it down
- Yeah.
- Break it down 'cause I wanna help.
- I wake up at six.
- Tell me the truth.
I want all, I need all real
data because if you give me
fake data, then we
fucking wasted your time.
Give me all real data.
What time do you go to sleep?
Tell me the fucking truth.
- Like 11.
- 11, what time you wake up?
- 5:36.
- Okay, listen, seven hours--
My son will wake up
in the middle of the night so I have to go
and like we live in 1000
square foot house, so--
- Yeah, so you gotta go, yep.
- If I'm up the house is up.
- Okay, so now break
it down, they wake up,
then what happens?
What's your workday look like?
- I will make breakfast
with them which I love.
So, we kind of do all of that,
We will make breakfast
then I start running around the stores
and yet getting the things
that I need for the jobs
and get to work and then
I'll clock out mentally
by like four o'clock
because I do wana be home for dinner.
I do wanna be home to
read the books to them.
I wanna do all that.
- So, first of all, a couple things.
Do you know how epic it is
to be a world class father
and just be a solid businessman?
- Yeah, that's, I'm happy.
That's the thing, when I
texted you the question,
I'm like, I'm the
happiest fricking person.
In my life, but like there's that one guy
that just keeps poking me and it's like
the drive inside of me that like,
dude go big, go big go big.
- Yeah, I mean four o'clock
is like the second or third,
maybe halftime, not even halftime for me.
But I'm not gonna have
the father like moments
that you have.
- Yeah.
I'm excited for him to be like five or six
and I get a plough truck and
we freaking start plowing
together and doing all that stuff,
starts (mumbles) the hustle.
- It gets really good when they get older.
Bro, there's nothing I mean,
honestly, I admire you,
and in a lot of ways envy you
because we don't have unlimited time.
You're right, there is no time machines.
There's no going back to these moments.
I think we have to stop judging ourselves.
You sound like a world class
father with a real healthy
work life balance like a modern day
healthy work life balance.
I'm a workaholic that balances
family and extremities
of weekends and vacations
and as long as there's love
overlaying both real love,
not bullshitting.
Not checking the box,
then
- No.
everyone's gonna win and
like that just chemicals.
There's a big part of me
that wishes there was,
my DNA could clock out at four o'clock.
- But I don't, that's the thing.
It's literally like being
a workaholic, though.
So, listen, now you have to explain to me
are you doing that because
you want to do that
for your wife and for your
parents or your friends
to look at you and admire you that way?
Or you're you doing it because
you're doing it for yourself?
- That's for myself because of I've--
- Bro you're making the choice, bro.
You (mumbles) making a choice.
- But it's for myself
I do know that.
- So, don't create a fake narrative
that you like the sound of it.
(mumbles)
- I do like,
I have self-reflection.
I can see what I'm like where
I'm trending or whatever.
I am grateful for being like
mentally straight about that,
'cause I know that I won't get that back
'cause 15 years from now, whatever,
I can start and end like a
multi billion dollar business
if I wanted to, where I
can more guide my kids
versus raise my kids.
- I think that's right.
I think that's right.
- I think lately because of you again,
because of you what's been
kind of satisfying my itch
at the social media stuff,
because I can do that then at nine,
at eight or nine o'clock online
and like TikTok and all that stuff.
So, that then gives me a
little bit of gratification
of I do get a following
because that's like
- It's an action, it's action.
- getting big.
- It's action.
- So.
- Listen, Misha.
I am the byproduct of a
father who I didn't see
until I was 14.
See, he slept in the same house
as me and I didn't see him.
And in that scenario, what was
your situation with your dad?
- So, when I was eight, my
dad left to United States.
- Mm hmm.
- Lived here for four years
- And then brought you over?
- to get us there because it ain't cheap,
especially back then you have some debts
so, you have to settle.
- Look, look.
We were two boys that have
scenarios with fathers
that weren't around.
And we went two different directions.
You were affected in a way
where you're like, fuck that,
I'm not gonna have my
kids feel that feeling
and you've gone deep.
I loved it.
I loved it and love my dad the most.
And so I've enormous comfort
and if I miss things,
or if I'm working and I don't see things
or if I'm not home for dinner,
that I'm okay with that.
And guess what?
Both are okay.
- Yeah.
- Your kids one day--
- So, that--
- Ready?
Let's talk about real life.
One day your kids at 22 will
look in and be like dad,
we're the luckiest in the world.
You're always around, that's amazing.
Or they may look at you and
say dad you around too much.
I don't have driver ambition
because even though you were
saying things you were
home around all the time,
and I got that from somewhere else.
My kids are gonna say, dad,
you showed me how to live
by living your passion.
It's made me so happy.
And all the good things we
were doing in different times.
I love that or they'll to say,
dad, you weren't around
enough and I resent you.
That's real talk.
There's always two sides
to every coin in life.
Well we need to do is do the
best we can we as parents,
we as humans, we as children,
who have parents pressuring us
to go to school and things of that nature
or get this some job, all
we can do, all we can do.
Every one of us that's on here right now,
all I can do is just do the best we can
and make decisions and then
live with those decisions
and not dwell on them.
We will make mistakes, we
will make right decisions.
We do not control our kids' DNA.
Some kids are naturally self-confident,
some are naturally insecure,
regardless of how you parent them.
There's a lot of things
that we don't control
and we need to be at ease with that.
- Yeah, I mean, the fact
that they were born healthy
and everything we're like, we good.
So, that's a massive part of
- There's people that have
horrible relationships with
their parents in the first
20 years because they're
alcoholics or embezzlement
or went to jail or hit their mom
or went away
- Yeah.
- and then later reconcile.
Don't be fear-based on
the parenting side either.
Because you're gonna...
- I mean, yeah.
- Because if you are,
then you're gonna resent
- Doing that, right.
- You're gonna resent your kids,
keeping you away from your true calling.
And it's not their fault, it's yours,
but that's how you're gonna manifest it.
That's what people do.
- Yeah, that's true.
- And then what I'm more
worried about is that you would
resent your loved ones
that you're trying to look the part for.
Or you're trying to
make a point to your dad
or things of that nature, this
is important shit, brother.
What I can tell you right now is
you need to do what makes you happy.
And you know the answer.
You just might be scared of the answer.
Or, this was just what
you needed to triple down
on what's going on.
Which by the way, there is
no time machines to go back
to your kids dinners, and
reading books and soccer games
and proms, and I think that's amazing.
I love it, makes me happy.
- Yeah, I just wanna have
those life experiences
for them and for myself.
- So then, we won.
- So, the part two of that,
I'm sorry this is dragging on
but like part two is like
then my, a generic question
for everybody I guess
is like as a contractor,
I wanna go the best route.
How do I go about branding
myself and kind of going about
- Producing content at scale.
Filming every project from
coast to coast documented,
get approval from the people's homes,
to share it, chop it up put
on Pinterest and Instagram,
Facebook and LinkedIn, Twitter
at scale, YouTube, podcast,
content, content, content,
every one of us is immediate...
When the fuck is everyone gonna understand
we're all media companies
and the more we produce
and the better we get at it,
the more good stuff will happen.
And I sit here for a fucking decade
saying the same fucking shit,
a bunch of fucking thousand times over.
It's the fucking answer.
- So easy too,
if you think about it.
- It's so easy,
I just need you to take four
to 5 p.m to film that shit,
because I still think no
matter how young your kids are,
5:30 is a good starting point too.
- Yeah.
- Or 11:30.
Audit, audit, audit, audit.
(mumbles)
- That's why I think if
I go niche by small scale
then the media stuff can
then have more time to do
because then you can
kind of focus on almost
two companies were a
media issue-like situation
and then your actual business business,
social contract there's man,
you have so much content
everything you do.
- Unlimited.
- On TikTok, you'll get--
- Testimonials at scale.
You do a good project, the
family lets you share the content
and then the last scene is them saying
you were fucking awesome.
That's why doing the
right thing for customers
is always right.
It builds your brand.
- Yeah, we're gonna try it the Zoom thing
'cause my wife, she does
she does the design.
So design build kind of chip
and Joanna and gain deal stuff.
- Love it, love it.
- So, I think we're trying
with today's situation.
Again, I'm trying to get
the positive out of it like,
hey, what if we do a Zoom meeting?
or live to help people like
hey, how do I start (mumbles).
- I wanna sneak one
more in before I'm out,
I love you brother.
- Yeah, sorry man.
- Take care of yourself.
No, nothing to be sorry about.
- I appreciate it.
- Take care.
Some are short, some are long.
That was interesting.
Bro.
- What's up dude?
- What's up?
- Thank you for squeezing me in.
I've been waiting for
this for a week (laughs).
- I'm happy to have you on,
please keep your eyes on the road.
I don't need some shit that
fucking alters my life of guilt.
So, you wanna (mumbles)
then you tall, all right.
- Yeah, listen, I wish
I would have been able
to post the picture
that I had on my office
a couple minutes ago but I
had to leave because of work.
The pictures I had working into wine.
'Cause that's what I do.
- I love it.
I sell wine, it would
have been perfect, right,
that you did your Wine advertising
but (mumbles).
- Good point, everybody.
Put it up here, winetext.com.
Put it up, Dustin, while I
talk Juan, go ahead, Juan.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So listen, let me give
you a little gamble of me.
I'm Cuban, down here from Miami.
- Mm hmm.
- I came from Cuba when I was 14.
And from the age of 15 till
23 was the mass with my dad
into a telecommunications company,
or the geek for the lab.
And right around the time
of my 30s, I had a baby,
and life started switching
around a little bit.
And then I was like, you know what?
I can't be in the office room anymore.
For nine to five, nine to 10, eight to 11,
whatever the time required it to be.
Me, with my dad and siblings,
we pushed out our family
businesses as much as we could.
And went through 2008 a week like nothing.
And now we're still pushing forward.
Now one of the things that I
wanted to talk to you about was
how do you move aside
from the family business
which I (mumbles), obviously.
And how do you keep a balance
between what was working
and what was not working?
Let me give you a little more details.
For example, all that time
that we were working together,
my dad had a very good
vision, which as a father,
now I'm thinking of adopting it, too.
And that is that two heads
being better than one.
And four heads can push a car
faster than just one head.
So, as a family--
- As long as long as
one person is the driver
and the other three
are pushing the wheels.
- Correct.
Yeah, so he's the driver.
We were all (mumbles) the wheel
to the point that right now
our entire family depends on, not depend,
well, it depends on that business.
- Yap.
- That we helped create.
We branched out.
And at this time we're
trying to come back in
after we've figured out our talents,
after we figure who we
were because at the time,
we were only
- Kids.
- being exploited as
much as my dad thought
that we could have exploited.
- Yep, makes sense.
- Honestly, we, obviously we all grew that
into different areas.
And the wine business ended up being
a completely random thing.
(mumbles) on top of your desk,
jump in it, make a good investment,
and then push it forward.
So, I wanted to ask you more or less.
What's your take on how
to balance your past
and family business?
And how would you act?
- I would--
- 'Cause the more...
- I would fully work on my passion
and build up that business,
so I didn't have to rely
on the financial aspects
of the family business.
- Okay, doable, of course.
Now, where do you see wine going to?
- Wine will be drank for the rest of time.
That's why God drank it.
(laughing)
- One other thing that I
wanted to actually congratulate
(mumbles) is that you've been
very inspirational to others.
And during his hard times,
I've seen you to be probably
one of the few people
that went at it head on.
You've given a lot of
content to a lot of people,
a lot of work to a lot
of people that right now
are doing absolutely nothing
except consuming content.
And honestly, I just wanted
to thank you for that.
- Thank you Yuan, thank you so much.
- It wasn't much...
This conversation wasn't
much to ask you anything.
But more to give me a
(mumbles) for all that you do.
- Yuan, I promise you.
I promise you the appreciation
I have for thank yous
is as high as it is for the
ability to answer some questions
that brings value, so I
appreciate that my friend
and get back to driving.
I love that you're passing everybody.
You drive fast like me, I like it.
Keep going Yuan.
- Dude, the street is
completely empty (mumbles).
- I don't care, I see you
passing cars and it fires me up.
I love passing fuckers.
(laughs)
I'll see you later.
Take care Yuan, thank you.
- All right take care,
have a good day.
- Thank you, buddy.
You too.
Take this off the screen.
Good day.
Good day, that was a little scary.
I don't like the video and
driving shit, it fucks me up,
though I think, if you
don't look at the...
I have no problem talking
like that because everyone's
talking on the phone anyway,
but it's the fucking looking
that fucks me a little bit.
Nonetheless, I appreciate everybody.
Should we sneak one quick one?
Let's do one quick one, real quick.
- One person that hung around, so.
Perfect (laughs).
- Perfect, real fast.
Alex.
(mumbles) What's up?
- What's good?
What's up, bro?
- Oh shit, I got real
fucking nervous real fast.
- Don't worry bro.
It's just me and you here.
Where are you from?
- I'm from Pennsylvania.
I'm actually 20 minutes
away from Philadelphia.
- I love it.
How you doing?
How have you been?
- I'm stressed, I'm tired, there...
I don't sleep anymore.
- Why?
I am--
Because there's a lot of
teenagers in my generation
that need mental support.
- Yeah.
- And are terrified
- to go get help.
So, I'm good at calming people down
and getting out of headspace
is because I've actually lost
10 people to suicide
and I'm terrified of it.
So now it's like I'm
constantly staying awake,
just calming people down, so it's...
- So, real quick brother.
You've had 10 friends, commit suicide.
- 10 people that I know, yeah.
- And of those, these are
kids that are in your school?
- Some of them we're like
family members, yeah.
- And so you're stressed
because you want to
provide value for people?
- Yes, and I'm also trying
to make it somewhere with BMX
and that's actually why
I joined here today.
I have a passion for bikes.
I don't care what style you ride.
I don't care who you are.
I don't care if you're
just gonna hop on a bike
and go cruise.
If you're gonna ride, that's great.
You're a phenomenal person.
- I love that.
- I have a passion, and I know everything.
I have 15 bikes that I've built on my own.
I loaned my friends bikes.
In my area, there's Chester right there.
I don't know how much
you know about Chester,
it's not a good place at all,
they're shootings every day.
And the group that we have started
is getting kids on BMX
bikes on Cruiser Bikes
and doing wheelies.
- What's it called?
What's your group called?
- What's our group called?
So, right, there was an
old group called One Way
but that stopped now.
So now, it's just us riding around.
- From what was One Way.
- One Way was a bunch
of kids doing wheelies
throughout Philadelphia streets
and it got into the city,
it got everywhere, it went nationwide.
- Who was the organizer
and why did it go away?
- It went away because the wheeling crew,
the scene just calmed down.
And now it's like there's
very few actual BMX riders.
It's still a scene, but it's small.
And in my area, there's no skate parks.
There's nothing, so we just have to use
the streets that we have.
- Yeah, I get it.
So how can I help you?
- So,
I want to start my own BMX company.
I have had this on my
mind for 10 years now,
I've almost been riding.
- How old are you?
- I'm 16.
- Okay, keep going.
My parents hate how much
time I put into BMX.
- And what do they want you to do?
- They--
- Sorry, I had to come in here
because I can relate to this a lot.
I ride just so you know.
- Let's stay here, Dustin, join us.
Keep going, go ahead Dustin.
- Well, I mean, I've known
people that started BMS companies
and then early 2000s
and that was a hard time
compared to now.
It's easier but harder because
of the situation right now
but if you think that's
something you wanna do,
just go for it.
I have a friend, started from scratch
that he started Merit with this friend.
- You're kidding.
- Yeah, so.
- Billy Carry
- You're part--
- I'm friends with Billy
too but Mike Brennan
and Sean Curran are the
ones that created Merit.
And they just started it.
They work that Animal first.
And then they just started from scratch.
They learned what they could from Animal
and then wanted to do their own thing.
And then just went off from there
and now like it's a big
company because, not huge,
but they do well.
And it's not impossible, I'm just saying.
- Alex, what are your...?
I know you're freaking out and
you want Dustin's autograph,
but real quick.
(laughs)
'Cause I gotta go to this fucking call.
What do your parents want you to focus on?
School?
- They want me to do school
and to get a scholarship for running.
- Because you're a great runner?
- I can sprint a four-12 mile.
- I don't know what that
means but sounds impressive.
So, why--
- I can finish a mile
in four minutes and 12 seconds.
- That sounds real fucking
fast, so what's that about?
You hate running?
- I do
- (mumbles) gifted?
- I completely hate it.
The only reason I started it was--
- Real quick.
What are your parents do?
- My mom--
- Dustin tell my admins
to push my next interview for
- My mom owns
- five ten minutes.
- three billboard companies
and my dad is manager
of four, is the manager
of the Tech Support
and engineering and stuff for
apartment complexes I think.
- Got it, where did your parents grow up?
- My dad grew up in Brumore.
And my mom grew up moving
everywhere because her dad,
my grandfather was in the
Marine so she lives in England.
She's lived in Paris.
- Were your parents good students?
- Very, my mom has like three degrees.
My dad wanted to be a lawyer,
but life got in the way.
- Yep, and what about siblings?
- My sister is taking
college classes right now,
she is a senior in high
school and she already has
almost all of her college
credits completed.
My brother is in seventh grade
and is taking 10th grade math
while I'm in 10th grade
taking eighth grade math.
- Yep.
- All my siblings are
intellectually gifted
and it's just me (mumbles).
- Bro you fucking run like a gazelle.
You're fucking gifted.
(laughs)
The only thing I'm
gifted at is knowing that
there's a clue behind
you and I can flip that
for $11 and 83 cents on eBay.
- They're all gifted in school
and I have a processing disability.
I have brain damage.
I have a lot of PTSD
and traumas and stuff.
I have a lot...
I have dyslexia and dysgraphia.
- Yep.
- Is also fucking me up.
- You do understand that
that's your strength
not fucking you up right?
- No, actually I don't, I've been--
- Let's talk about it.
You've been what?
- All of my teachers...
- When you say I don't--
Yeah, do you know how fucking...?
Fuck your teachers.
(laughs)
- They all said I was a
failure up until this year.
- Bro my teachers thought
I was the biggest loser of all time.
Have you ever seen my fucking report card?
- No, I had straight Fs (laughs).
- Me too bro.
You need to find my report card.
You're pulling it up Dustin?
Find it for this man.
Actually, no, let him figure it out.
Alex, you need to find my
report card on Instagram,
I've posted like four times.
Alex, you can not make
school grades a North star.
- Okay.
- Write that down nice and slow.
Not a North star, you
cannot have your validation
come from a game that doesn't
fit your natural strength.
Does that make sense to you?
Your parents want you
to be good at school?
- Yes, they actually--
- Tell me the truth, they do?
- Yes, they do.
They actually pushed me to staying up
until around three in the morning
and waking up at six in
the morning every day.
- Are you shitting on your parents?
Or are you being dead fucking serious?
- No, I'm being dead serious.
They incredibly push, they're
pushing me past every single
one of my mental and physical capabilities
so I can do well in school.
- So what are we gonna do about that?
- I don't know (laughs).
- You need to have a real talk with them.
- I have.
- And how did those talks go?
- Basically, they told me
that they know me better
than I know my own self.
That they only have my
best interests at heart.
- You know that's not true, right?
You know that they have
a prayer of knowing,
not even a fucking prayer
you can quote me on this to their face.
They can call me, they can come see me.
I'm more than happy to
have a convo with them.
They don't have a fucking
prayer of knowing you
better than you know yourself.
Not even in the fucking universe.
Not even fucking universe, bro.
They have no fucking clue
what's in your fucking dome.
- I've never opened up to any of them.
And my mom claims that she's
like my person to go to
when I haven't opened up to
someone since my best friend
killed herself after
calling me five times, so.
- Bro, listen.
Of course, there's a ton
of fucking shit, right?
But you have to start
having real conversations
with your parents for real for real,
then you need to start pushing back
on things that aren't true.
- (laughs) That's scary.
- Of course it's scary.
Everything good is scary.
You wanna remember,
riding a bike is scary.
I'm scared shitless
and start riding a bike
until I was nine,
you fuckers, you and Dustin
are fucking whiz kids.
And at six you're popping wheelies.
I was scared as fuck to skin my knee.
- Six, I think I was actually
trying to 540 over my ramp.
- Yeah, I have no idea what
the fuck you just said.
But I promise you right
now, when I was nine,
I didn't want to ride a
bike 'cause skinning my knee
sounded like the worst
fucking thing of all time,
but telling my parents who the fuck I was,
was easy as fuck.
Everything good is scary.
- And just so you know,
my parents to this day
still don't support me riding BMX.
She's always saying stop riding your bike.
And I'm 35 (laughs).
- You're 35?
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Dustin, you look 19.
I'm so fucked up right now.
What the fuck?
This show's over.
Alex, send me an email, I
wanna keep talking to you,
but I gotta get out of here.
I love you.
It's Gary (mumbles).
Dustin will take care of it.
Everybody, thanks for the show.
Alex, thanks for being on.
There's way more intensive.
We're gonna probably bring you back on.
Get him out of here.
Dustin, see Alex, I know
you got a ton of shit,
and I got to go.
I love everybody very much.
I know that was a little abrupt.
But the fucking Dustin 35
year old thing fucked me up.
Now, we've got work to do with Alex.
But we also have some real work to do.
They're ungodly levels of
people who are hungry right now
because the food infrastructure is broken.
We have started the All in Challenge.
Michael Rubin, the founder of Fanatics
outside of Pennsylvania ironically enough,
allinchallenge.com,
Michael Rubin, the founder of Fanatics
is a friend called me a couple days in
after he kinda thought
of and started and said,
I need you stepped up
with our friend Alan Tisch
and our incredible teams of VaynerMedia
and Fanatics have launched
the All in Challenge
and it's completely exploded.
Maybe you've seen all these crazy things
that Drake and Justin
Timberlake and Matthew Connie
and Kevin Hart and Meek Mill,
and on and on and on have given away.
It's exploding.
I've given away the
Ultimate GaryVee Experience.
You can buy raffle ticket for 10 bucks,
you can buy 20 of them for 100 bucks.
I would like every person
here, if they can afford $10
to go right now to
garyvee.com/allinchallenge
and what I'm giving away is in video form,
it's gonna to play right now,
if you haven't seen the video yet,
you're gonna lose your fucking mind.
I went fucking ham.
I hope you check it out,
if you happen to to join it
please let me know on Twitter,
I'm on Twitter paying attention
to everything you did.
Play the video Dustin.
I am giving away the
Ultimate GaryVee Experience.
How should I go?
Okay.
Over the last week or so I've been a gym
with my friend Michael Rubin
and helping out on this
All in Challenge
that I am accepting right
now but allinchallenge.com,
please go there.
We are challenging some
of the greatest artists,
entertainers, athletes in the
world to provide a ridiculous
all-time experience or one
of their most iconic items
in their collection to help raise money
to help feed the hungry
during this ridiculous time,
so now, I have to put up my auction.
So my auction the Ultimate
GaryVee Experience here we go.
I'm gonna go off the top of the head.
And you can go on allinchallenge.com
to go bid on this.
I am giving away...
Okay, you get to in the course of the year
you will go garage selling
with me and film Trash Talk.
Also you can get a workout
with me and Mike Vacanti.
So, I know a lot of you pay attention
to that part of my world.
Also, we're gonna go to Wine Library
and do a $25,000 shopping spree.
That's right.
I'm gonna pay my dad (laughs).
Well, I'm gonna donate.
We're gonna pay my dad 25,000
so $25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library.
I will walk through the
whole store with you
tell you the war stories.
And you'll buy a bunch
of wine, beer, liquor,
whatever you want, food.
We are going to go to
a Jets game together.
You're going to tailgate with me.
I never do this when I
give away Jets tickets.
I never let the person sit with me,
so you will sit with me
during the Jets game.
I won't talk to you during the game.
I'm completely focused but you'll get that
so the ultimate Jets experience, tailgate,
full game with me as well.
Also, I'm going to give you
one week play at VaynerMedia,
so this is for you and
a plus one, by the way.
So two tickets, we'll do some plus ones,
we'll do some just me and
you depending on what it is.
One full week at VaynerMedia
getting consulting
and business advice
from Team GaryVee and me
for the entire week hanging out in the pit
where the show's done.
You're gonna be a guest of my podcast.
We're gonna do a wine dinner for you
and seven of your friends
at Hunt & Fish Club
in New York City.
And I'm gonna fly you, all paid, plus one,
to three of my keynotes, and
we'll work on those details.
The Ultimate GaryVee experience.
I hope you bid on it.
I hope you get involved.
I hope we raised a lot of money
to help people that need it,
also what's so fun about
the All in Challenge is
you get to challenge people to be in it.
I am gonna challenge all
the VaynerSports athletes.
I expect you in there.
So that is number one.
Number two I'm gonna go with
ooh, you know what?
Timberland, the super producer
who's completely lighting up Instagram.
Timberland, the super
producer, I'm calling you out.
And finally, I got one.
The Undertaker, one of the
great wrestlers of all time.
Please join the challenge.
Everybody go to allinchallenge.com.
Please support this.
The experiences are gonna be nuts.
We've been working bleeding
out of the eyeballs
for the last week putting
this all together,
you're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see
on social media #allinchallenge.
Please check it out.
And please go to your
favorite celebrities, athletes
and entertainers and leave #allinchallenge
to get them involved.
The All in Challenge.
Please take it.